thank you good day what  well Merry Christmas and a Happy New  Year have a good one merry Christmas  everyone in the gore district a very  Merry Christmas and a Happy New Year  Merry Christmas  you are a very very happy new year  [Applause]  nearly a Christmas everyone I really  hope you have a really fantastic time  with family friends and look for to  catching up with your again in 201 eight  very Christmas  [Music]  wishing everyone a very Merry Christmas  and a safe India for all another the  center - yes for the poor District  Council we'd like to wish you a very  Merry Christmas and a safe and happy new  year on the team of the gore district  council just want to wish you a really  heavy Christmas and hope the 2018 brings  all the hopes and dreams that you aspire  to